entirely possible this could be the end
of the Rich Eisen great working with you
guys a pharaoh the star of the new
half-hour comedy series white famous on
Showtime that debuts in a couple of
Sundays October 15th at 10:00 p.m.
Eastern and 10:30 p.m. Eastern with
back-to-back episodes good to see you
sir oh it's good to be here
it's good to be rich it's great to be
here they're putting you were over there
putting yeah you drained only when it
was not the camera not the camera wasn't
only what I drained it I don't believe
oh man you know what they say if it
doesn't happen on camera it doesn't
happen at all shoot I did it though just
letting everybody know I drained that
puts on a foot pot you just you just
started I just I died I channeled I
channeled mine my Tiger Woods was swag
and I did it with swag no do Tigers no
way sound uh uh you know those tapes
would I know it's old news but those
tapes were atrocious like that made him
sound like a punk like can I say to be
where it's true for sure maybe some like
[ __ ] oh yeah I like your oh I want you
to want you to come over my house and
rub your feet oh all over you like sucks
toes
[Music]
what was the thing that I just saw what
the person had defeat on the for the
airplane what was up that's my buddy
Chris Brockman because he likes taking
shoes off on an airplane Jay and I have
not represent a ssin of myself you know
what that that's that dense weed because
I I've had somebody do that to me and
this guy he was an Indian dude he had
one of them Sub Zero mask on his face
y'all talking about and then he was he
took his shoes off he was rotating his
foot and I'm already I was at yo man
this dude is gonna I was like this dude
is gonna call for me and give me
something and then he's gonna put his
foot in my mouth like that's what my
mind went like exactly I don't need
somebody to take their shoes off on a
plane yeah
together for any for however long the
flight lasts unless you girl you know if
a lady does it when she does this that's
kind of sexy but if it's a dude that's
weird
he's weird when a dude does this like
why would you do this I you shouldn't
even the karlitz shouldn't even do that
in your foot like you shouldn't even be
able to rotate like this and wave it
around the any sort of just wafting your
foot oh why are you trying to waft the
foot out I don't need foot woof I don't
need that I don't need a toe total
emissivity munoz you know what I'm
saying that's weeds what I'm saying I'm
just saying Pharaoh and I are locked in
together hey white famous yes you are
bringing to life the personal
experiences of the great Jamie Foxx yes
correct
so basically he's put together how he
started and how he launched his career
essentially it's loosely based off of
it's loosely based off of Jamie's
experiences um it's it's the story of
you know a black comedian on the
underground circuit who gets a chance to
cross over into the industry and like a
lot of us have that story like that's my
story that's that's Eddie's story that's
Chris's story that's Kevin's story
that's like all electricy stories yes is
this all of our stories so I related to
the mature cuz I know how that is I know
how it is doing those $50 $75 rooms and
some hole in the wall with a whole bunch
of Jamaican shaking keys and stuff like
I know about that like you gotta go to
New York like in New York there's this
place called footprints and if you don't
do good they shape the keys at you blood
clot by a get y'all forget get off this
stage no you're not funny at all let me
be funny if we come up there no we get
you know we pop blood clot you say one
more ting you just want to get out of
there yeah but I never got the keys
shaking at me it was they like you know
luckily you know impressions trance in
two other of the coaches yes so they
know they black blood clotted but sound
you like Obama you know
so what's that it was never I never had
a problem with those rooms but I know I
know how it is with that grind so it's
that story right and you know Jamie has
been nothing but a big brother to me and
he's really you know looked at he'd be
like you know what man if you need
anything just let me know I'll let me
let me know what the fizzle with the
feizi cuz you know that's how that's how
he talks is that you know je mange
I don't understand man you were so
talented you are so talented last night
me and my dogs were hanging uh no he
sings randomly I had one too many drinks
were you hang out with this guy yes he
will come into you you could be at a
bodega I don't know maybe you were
around
he called you up were you at I'm at
Ralph's look coming in with his backpack
with his music playing his own
soundtrack there's nothing like being by
a chick at Starbucks in a rouse and he's
playing I had one too many drinks and
she's like oh she's freaking out and
messing up the orders because he's Jamie
Foxx and she wants to smash secretly I'm
gonna get you sucker where you travel
around with your only yeah your own
music yeah your own soundtrack I feel
like my theme music if I had some theme
music I feel like it will probably be
either Smashing Pumpkins butterfly
bullet wings you know that one or it
would be emo gene heap hide and seek so
that would be your Walker that would be
that would be your walk-up music that's
my er of a major league baseball player
that's about it yeah it's interesting
though cuz you know you and Jamie Foxx
you are a Rams fan yes Jamie Foxx is a
Cowboys fan yeah your Rams just stuck it
Jamie Foxx is Dallas cats right how you
like them apples which one I'm looking
at Troy this one right there you like
them apples Fox yeah we got you that's
right we got you we beat you big time oh
oh you thought you was gonna win but no
no cuz Jared golf
through that he got through it and you
can't do nothing about it but shout-out
to all the victims and uh Houston I know
listen I gotta work on my people skills
however however I am work but
listen man I love it I think um I
honestly think we're gonna go to the
playoffs this year hopefully is the
number one offense no doubt right now on
everything you're just so in case people
don't think that Jay Pharoah is a
bandwagon jumper because they're just
here in Los Angeles right you're new to
Los Angeles you spent all those years in
New York doing Saturday Night Live yep
and you're from Virginia I love the Rams
from the from from the gate you know I
like them because they were my team or
NFL Blitz I was always always got him
you did the greatest show on turf on NFL
Blitz Joe Marshall yo Marshall Marshall
Faulk II would kill it and then the head
his head would get huge and he'd be
spinning he could go and you'd be on
fire oh I love blitz blitz
I don't like Madden let me tell you I
don't like Madden now not John Madden
personally I've never met him talking
about the game right I don't like the
game because my father learned how to do
offside onside kicks it was awesome
onside kicks and he just kept kicking
the ball to himself so I was like well
forget mad and I was like mm - I haven't
played in 15 years so you dropped it I
dropped Madden because my dad learned
and evolved
but dude uh yeah dawg dude I want to go
to a game I want to go to a game hey
listen hook me up with some tickets
there's come on Rams what's happening
you want to give him your tickets J if
you got some cash lying around I'll sell
you my tickets some cash he's white
famous you just give him the tickets
he's got cash lying around that's how
that works
I'm do I do but I'm black remember
there's no point today well it means I
still look man meaning I still do I
still do things that I did before I made
it that's all I'm saying I keep the
groundedness you know I mean I stayed
ground humble I stay humble couple
moments here with Jeff Aaron did you
have you ever done your Denzel for
Denzel I've never met Denzel
Lenny Kravitz actually showed the clip
of me doing
Will Smith and Denzel to him in 2010 I
never in when I saw when I sold Lenny
Kravitz at Chateau de amor is more money
that's what's going on I was just there
last night I'm some messing it up but he
said that he showed him the clip and
then Denzel was like that's pretty good
that's a good uh hey does he eat this
well he does or there's Will Smith well
as well he's he's really good the kid is
good how old is he he's 22 what he's 22
get the hell out of here my man okay all
right I see you I see you
mm-hmm Oh pop pop pop pop oh he just
starts going into random songs I wish
that's my Denzel impression he goes into
randomness no because I have a TD but
you know so you've never met him never
met NIMS oh I met Edie I met Eddie and
that was I met him I was at the SNL 40th
and louis c.k was beside me and I was
like Lou is that it over there Lucy Kidd
was like yeah sure you want to meet him
I was like yeah can i you went over went
over there I'm still working on the
impression by the way went over there to
Eddie Murphy he goes as his J furie was
a big fan of yours and URI is an Eddie
Murphy was like Oh years refined know
exactly who you are yes yes yes you're
very talented
no me and ice any we watch your stuff
and man you know me you're so intricate
with the details you know about your
Will Smith I don't know how you do the
Will Smith but notice it's amazing at
that point at that point I'm going to
fool Viola Davis from my fences mode I'm
sitting there snotting yeah I mean she
snotted you know I mean she had she made
physical snide drop from the crevices of
her sinuses that's what she did right so
that's you getting a little wet over
there my walk away now Jay Pharoah here
on the show Sunday October 15th 10:00
Eastern and then right after that the
back-to-back episode debut of white
famous what is white famous for those
who might be unfamiliar Jay what is that
what does it determine yes sir
the term means being internationally
known are known by known by the world
and accepted
in everybody's life that's what white
famous is and I mean you know any heart
feel come on rich you're already there I
mean it's pretty much default come on
man I got a little work to do you feel
me a couple more a couple more meetings
with a couple of meetings with Diddy I'm
playing I'm playing JD I'm playing I'm
playing that guy's he's weird all right
yeah man but white Fame that's what
white famous is and this dude the show
is the show is we have such a good
chemistry everybody's good on the show
yep you know Cleo Coleman uh you know
Jacob Ming Trent
Lonnie Chavis Michael Rapaport Natalie
Zia Jack Davenport Meghan good Oh harsh
like everybody is good on the show and
Jamie Foxx and Jamie is Jamie's Jamie is
Jamie
I couldn't personate the hairline you
know you've been watching it for a while
yes Ben its back it's funny Barkley
yesterday called me out on Dan Patrick
show to shave to see sex buddy it's not
that I've lost it I need to come home is
what he said listen man listen listen
what rich need to do is rich just need
to come on home there's nothing else top
trying to hold on to the past
listen I know slavery happened but
listen it happened all right just let it
let the things go just let it go just
shave it all off because it is very
shiny it's very shiny you ever seen the
apples that you put on a teacher's desk
look a little flared a little shine
that's what it is when you get this
shine it's time play the actual real
record stick how close you realize oh
man I need one more favor for you okay
I got a hurry till Rich Eisen it's time
to come home listen listen a lot of
battles have happened in your life but
the war the war ultimately is lost you
need to come on home lick your wounds
and come on home
Charles Barkley man you know who else
need to shave they eat stuff yeah and
he's young too but Kevin Durant yo he
need to get rid of that I don't know
what's happening you either that a hair
Club one of them man cuz I've seen it
it's like a [ __ ] brillo pad ish you
know I'm sayin and up here it looked
like her you ever seen it yeah can I say
his work you ever seen a scrotum yeah
that's how that's how it looks it's
right
Durant man yo look at the back of his
jaw look at the back enjoy you need the
fibers like you need to put the fibers
in there I think LeBron suddenly yo you
see yo he's he's cut it now he's you
happen to Jordan Jordan used to have a
full head of hair two seasons came on
that hype and it was gone that's what
the hype does to your head makes you
bald that's what I hope I have had the
white famous Deon put it back Deon
restored he did he did he's gotten it
done you know what there's nothing and
there's nothing to be ashamed of fellas
listen my head was going for a little
bit
give me some lasers done hey get it
taken care of you got the money doing
like that is the truest quote ever yo
get it if it yo why not
you walk around here with like this say
like Stephen H Smith is my guy but yo
man eight every year I see it in an inch
just just runs away just disappears to
the minister hoodwinked bamboozled let
us stray run
mock and flat-out to see he's describing
his hairline he'll take the job
listen we have been bamboozled we've
been hoodwinked I don't understand it
every time I look in the mirror it's
just another inch and it just leaves I'm
just trying to you know at this point it
just looks like a baby bunny that's what
it looks like yeah yeah baby you know
how you should do the thing one two way
back you know the football exercises
that's my hairline
one two way back that's what it is
LeBron James me you know Charles Barkley
of course you know Shannon Sharpe he's
got a full head of hair but he can't
talk for anything I don't understand
what's happening
you know much size willing to Steven
Smith ran so long fantastic oh my god
feel good though right get that off your
chest
oh my gosh oh man Steven Naismith
dutiful Calla T of the ink officiousness
of this situation now I don't understand
what he was doing but what he was trying
to prove but what I'm trying to prove to
you is that if you look in the mirror
you know get it done just say white
famous white Fame on Showtime Sunday
October 15th at 10:00 and 10:30 p.m.
Eastern before I let you go I've got
about a minute left or so for you to say
what your life goal is yeah what is your
life goal my new life goal everybody's
watching me
my life goal is to be Oprah's baby daddy
yes that's what I want to do I want to
be Oprah's baby daddy man I don't care
Stedman you ain't you ain't hitting it
right Stedman ain't doing supposed to do
Oprah Oprah come on home baby
listen hey who else could be like yo son
yo my baby mamas just got me a black
rhino and like like yo she's got the
other one and these are the only two
left ever like who else could say that
that's all I want I just want to be able
to talk trash the women want to break up
yeah I mean they want to break over me
if we get to that point like I want to
leave you I don't like you no more you
know I'm saying you're just too
egotistical I'll be like listen I play
really let's do the levels here as a JV
because I'm Oprah's baby daddy everybody
else come on what are you gonna do
Michael Jackson did the same thing when
somebody tried to break off Michael
Jackson it was the same exact thing
really really you say the B word really
[ __ ] really really you want to break up
with me [ __ ] really come on let's do
the levels okay this levels this levels
[ __ ] this levels Michael Jackson
everybody else that's what it is who's
your ex-boyfriend what's your
ex-boyfriends name my name is dish I
don't know I use the same girl voice but
that's the girl voice my boyfriend name
is Deshawn okay Michael Jackson
everybody else dish on digs a hole
you [ __ ] next Sunday are a couple
Sundays October 10th Eastern and then
they back-to-back episode of come back
any time are you I'm sure well you're
you're hilarious
thank you Mary enjoyed hanging out thank
you rich Jay Ferrel white famous and
Oprah's baby daddy all rolled into one
Oprah's baby daddy o P D the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches